okay so the topic of this video is
classification and taxonomy so let's get
started so when we talk about
classification in texanne taxonomy we
should really start with carolus
linnaeus and kind of what he's most
famous for is creating the system called
binomial nomenclature this is the system
of given every organism two names and
I'm willing to bet you've heard examples
of binomial nomenclature for instance
you might know that humans have the
scientific name of Homo sapiens two
names homo and sapiens that's an example
of a binomial nomenclature and so in in
this system of giving every organism two
names the first word is a broader word
and in general this category is called
the genus category and it tends to be
more broad and the second word tends to
be more specific and the second word is
called the species name and so if we
look at two examples really quick
carolus linnaeus represent in humans on
the left and we have a model on the
right depicting Homo erectus but you
might know that the genus for both
humans and Homo erectus is Homo see what
I mean by it's a broader category it
applies to more than just one organism
but the species name is unique to both
of these on the Left we have say sapiens
on the right we have erectus so when we
combine the two the genus and the
species of humans would be Homo sapiens
when we combine the two the genus and
the species you have homo erectus and so
this is the scientific name of the
binomial name of humans Homo sapiens and
then of Homo erectus
if we look at some formatting really
quick you know if you're typing the
binomial name of an animal where's a cow
the genus name of a cow is the word
bossed notice how its capitalized and
the species name of a cow is Taurus
notice how it has been lowercase and
because you're typing it tends to be an
italicized print if handwritten it's
really no different other than instead
of italicized in the names it's
underlined the genus boss is still
capitalized the species named Taurus is
still lowercased you know here's another
example a gray wolf the if typed the
grey wolf the genus is keenest and
notice again how it's been capitalized
and the species name is lupus notice how
it is again in lowercase and because
this is tight it's an italicized print
but of hand written again it's still
Canis lupus the genus is still
capitalized but if handwritten the only
difference is underlying the two words
well you know you might be thinking you
know what's the point what's the point
of giving every organism a binomial name
can't I just call this thing a jellyfish
well you can but the problem is in the
name in the title jellyfish there's a
couple things that are misleading number
one they're not fish and number two
they're not actually made out of jelly
so you see when we use common names it
can be a little misleading
another misleading common name would be
a seahorse you know calling this thing a
seahorse you know hopefully you
recognize well it's it's not a horse
these aren't mammals like horses like
horses that gallop on land
you know seahorses are fish you know
here's another example a starfish again
a starfish just because it lives in in
the ocean and in the waters that doesn't
make it a fish and starfish by no means
are fish but their common name might
imply that they are a fish another good
example would be a prairie dog you know
a prairie dog the name implies that it's
in the dog family
in actuality prairie dogs are rodents
and they're more in common with mice and
rats so common names can be a little
misleading well here's another example
of why you know common names can be a
bit confusing well here's a picture of a
puma here's a picture of a cougar and
here's a picture of a mountain lion if
you're thinking well it's just the same
picture you're right it is because in
some parts of the world these cats are
called Pumas in other parts of the world
these cats are called Cougars and in
other parts of the world these cats are
called mountain lions and so it makes
you think that these are three different
species when in reality they are the
same species Puma concolor and so the
genus again is the name Puma and the
species name is bone color and so that's
kind of the the way that binomial names
work it removes some of this confusion
and so one of the problems that went
that we encountered in our early years
of classifying life is you know with
Linnaeus and some of the other
scientists at their time they didn't
have some of the fancy tools that we
have you know DNA analysis and such and
so they built their classification
system based around physical features
and you can easily understand why you
know sharks and dolphins at one time
we're thought to be very closely related
how animals they both live in the oceans
they have similar smooth streamlined
body fins and flippers but upon you know
closer analysis you know we can see that
this this system led to many errors but
upon closer analysis you know we realize
that sharks and dolphins are quite
different animals I mean sharks are
members of the fish category and
dolphins are mammals you can you can
easily imagine at one time mushrooms
were thought to be very closely related
to plants because again they grow out of
the ground they kind of look like plants
turns out again mushrooms and and plants
are actually very different from one
another and so when we only use physical
features we kind of run into problems
so the solution that has popped up in
recent decades has been using DNA to
analyze and show relatedness if we look
at the DNA of the flower on the left
with its a's t's c's and g's and the DNA
of the fungus on the right with its a's
t's c's and g's we notice a lot of
differences well this tells us that
fungus and plants are very distantly
related they don't have much in common
well how can we tell of these three
flowers which flower is more you know
closely related to the blue one in the
middle well if we examine the DNA of the
three if we examine the a's t's c's and
g's of the of the blue flower in the
middle and compare it to the one on the
left maybe there's only one base pair
that's different between them but on the
right if we compare the one on the right
to the middle we might see more
differences well this is how we can use
the DNA to analyze which of these
flowers is most related based on this
information I could conclude that the
two flower species on the left are most
closely related to one another and so as
we move on into taxonomy taxonomy is the
science of classifying life according to
shared characteristics and what we're
going to introduce what I'm going to
introduce you to are the levels of
classification the levels of taxonomy
each individual level is called a taxon
you might know that they start off very
broad the taxon called domain is the
broadest of the categories and then
every taxon underneath it becomes a
little more specific Kingdom and then
file them and then class and then order
and within an order could be many
families within a family could be many
genus within a genus could be many
species and so you see the levels become
more and more specific as you go down
now one thing you might have a hard time
remembering is just kind of the order so
sometimes it helps to make a little
mnemonic memory trick and so maybe
something like dear King Philip
came over for good spaghetti something
silly make up your own of course but
something silly just say you remember
the order of these taxonomy levels and
the point of this is to easily show
relationships and you'll see a good
examples of that in just a moment well
let's look at an example of how we can
use those taxonomy levels to show
relationships let's look at the taxonomy
levels of a leopard you can see there's
a bunch of organisms in this collage and
a leopard being one of them well if I
were to say a leopard is in the broad
category the domain called Eukarya
Eukarya eukaryotes these are organisms
whose cells have a nucleus and
membrane-bound organelles or not
everything in this collage is a UK is in
domain Eukarya the bacteria that's
flashing they're not in the domain
called Eukarya but everything else is in
this domain called eukaryote so you can
see what I mean by it's a very broad
category but the next level down should
be a little more specific the next level
down would be the Kingdom called an
Amalia look at the collage not
everything in this collage that's
remaining is an animal the tree and the
mushroom are flashing because they are
they've been eliminated they're not in
the kingdom called
an Amalia but all the other organisms
that you see are so even though kingdom
Animalia is a little more specific it's
still pretty broad but the next level
down should be even a little more
specific the next level down being the
phylum called Chordata these are animals
with backbones and so right now the
snail the crab and the insect they're
flashing because yes these are animals
but they are not animals with backbones
so the next level down phylum Chordata
you can see is a little more specific
but it's still pretty broad so the next
level down should add even more clarity
more specificity and so of the collage
and the animals that are remaining which
of
are in the class called Mammalia the
mammals well the fish the eagle and the
frog are flashing because they're not
mammals but all the organisms that are
left are so you can see every level down
becomes a little more specific than the
one before it but still the category of
mammals is still pretty vague there's a
lot of mammals so the next level down
should add even a little more clarity
the order leopards are in an order by
the name of carnivore the carnivores the
meat-eaters
well that would eliminate the gorilla in
the rabbit but you can still see there's
still a good number of meat-eating
mammals so even the next level down
should add even more clarity leopards
are in a family by the name of felidae
the feline family
well that would eliminate the bear and
the wolf bears and wolves are not cats
and so in the felidae family we have
these three the lion the cougar and the
leopard but even at this lower level you
can see it's still kind of kind of broad
so the next level down leopards are in a
genus by the name of Panthera
well that would eliminate the cougar
Cougars in a different genus category
but the lion and the leopard are both in
the genus called Panthera so even at
this very very very lower level here
well second to the last level you can
see that it's still somewhat broad
because it applies to more than one
species and finally leopards are the
species name is partes and so that would
eliminate our lion and so we finally
have the taxonomy levels of a leopard
here
let me bring back these three animals
the rabbit the lion and the leopard and
kind of compare and contrast all three
of them I want to show you how these
levels of organization these tax ons can
allow us to see relationships well
they're all in the same domain the
domain called Eukarya all of these have
cells with a nucleus and membrane-bound
organelles they're all also in the same
Kingdom Kingdom called an Amalia rabbits
lions and leopards are all animals
they're all in the same fat a phylum
called Chordata their animals with
backbones so right now they're classic
and what our classification levels are
identical to one another and even right
the next level down the fourth level of
the class the class called Mammalia
rabbits are mammals lions are mammals
and leopards are mammals look so far
they're in the same classification
levels but now we're gonna start to see
some differences in the lion and the
leopard are in the order called
carnivore but the rabbit is in the order
called lagomorpha i hope i pronounced
that right as we continue down the lion
and the leopard are in the family called
Felidae as we saw a moment ago but a
rabbit is in the family called Lepore a
day which I always thought was kind of
ironic because it looks like the word
leopard I'm sure it doesn't mean leopard
in in Greek or Latin as we continue down
the lion and the leopard are in the
genus called Panthera and which is
different than the genus of the rabbit
I'm not even gonna try to pronounce some
of these and then lastly the species
name is where the lion and the leopard
differ from one another this the full
species name of the leopard would be
panthera pardus
the full species name of a lion would be
Panthera leo and the full species of the
of the rabbit would be the genus word
and the species word together and so
when I look at this picture here I can
really see nicely that the lion and the
leopard are most closely related because
they have seven out of those eight
levels in common they're rabbit and the
leopard or you can say they're a band
and have four out of the eight levels
encountered so this is what I mean
meant earlier when I said we can use
classification levels to see
relationships and as I finish up this
video here I just kind of want to
highlight the domains and the Kingdom
levels the taxon of the two taxon is at
the top the domain and the Kingdom
levels and so when it comes to the
domain there are three big broad
categories or domains one of them is
called the domain bacteria and these are
prokaryotic cells prokaryotic cells lack
a nucleus and other membrane-bound
organelles they have a chemical in their
cell wall called peptidoglycan and then
there's the domain called the archaea
like bacteria archaea are also
prokaryotic they lack this peptidoglycan
in their cell wall and one of their more
I guess well-known characteristics is
their ability to survive in incredibly
harsh locations I'll mention a few in a
moment and then there's the domain as we
said earlier the domain called Eukarya
these are eukaryotic organisms their
cells possess in nucleus and
membrane-bound organelles now within
these domains is the next level down the
next level down being the kingdoms and
currently classification most would kind
of argue that there are six
classifications kingdoms
however these these kingdoms are fluid
they've they've been updated over the
years and will continue to be updated
some will argue that the six kingdom
classification system might be a little
outdated but right now I think most tend
to recognize six kingdoms of life and so
within the domain bacteria is the
kingdom called you bacteria these are
the common bacteria the everyday
bacteria that we encounter in our day to
day life the reason why we practice good
hygiene these are the bacteria such as
ecoli that might live in our intestines
and and in some cases could get a sick
in the domain Archaea there's the
kingdom called archaea not very original
I know
some people call this kingdom the
archaea bacteria and I said they can
live an extremely harsh environment such
as really really salty locations much
saltier than the oceans really really
hot locations and even anaerobic no
oxygen environment and then within the
domain Eukarya there's actually four
kingdoms the kingdom called Protista
these are one tend to be single-celled
organisms like amoebas and paramecia
that swim around
typically in watery locations and then
there are kind of the three big kingdoms
that i think everybody recognizes the
fungus the plants and the animals and if
you're in my class we're gonna go into
more details on these kingdoms another
day but I just wanted to introduce the
three by three domains and the six
kingdoms okay so as I wrap up this video
you know if you're in my biology class
you know pause the video and try to
answer these questions I'd be happy to
check your answers before school or
after school one day thanks for watching